do I think with what air sword naturally
exposed to as opposed to what they're
not because we've been talking about
things that I think social argumentation
is there it's familial thing it's a
thing that you do I you know when my
younger son was very young he wanted me
to tell him stories about my life before
bed and a lot of times I was really busy
and it was late and I wanted to get him
to bed quickly and so I would say okay
I'm gonna tell you story that when I was
a little boy one day I got up and I had
breakfast you know Cheerios I climbed my
favorite tree I went in I had lunch you
know grilled cheese sandwich I went out
again I played in the yard I went in I
had dinner spaghetti and meatballs I
read a book and I went to bed the end
and he and he got so frustrated and I
said I told you a story but when I was a
little boy and he said it's not a story
it's not a story and so then I thought
okay I'm gonna play with this a little
bit what makes a good story because he
didn't use the kinds of terms that we
would he know he knew what a good
stories have certain kinds of structures
and certain complications and they have
resolution so at the age of about four
or five you knew what a good story was
and so I think a lot of students all
students have lots and lots of discourse
knowledge but what what is the discourse
what have they not been exposed to what
kinds of tests and this is an issue when
you look at elementary education there's
such a focus on imaginative written
discourse there's such a focus on
storytelling and much less on other
kinds of genre and you just don't meet
they don't get exposed to scientific
articles and op-ed and so on um so they
wouldn't if you gave him a bad one they
wouldn't say that's not a good op-ed
right I mean they don't have that so so
one thing I think we have to think about
is what students are exposed to as a
matter of course which I think will be
amenable to
kind of transfer if we make it explicit
enough and what is it what is our they
never exposed to that we need to expose
them to so that's that's one issue the
other thing I wanted to say about I
thought Nancy said something interesting
about you know about this notion of
engagement on a response level and I
think we ought to think about that on a
curricular level because we're still
used particularly in writing programs
we're so used to giving students
assignments that are completely
disconnected from each other every two
weeks we expect them to do brilliant
things with no knowledge at all you know
supposed to write great make great
arguments in May cases with no chance to
really immerse themselves and the stuff
that they're writing about and it brings
to mind some work that David Jolliffe
did many years ago on a sort of inquiry
guided learning where students would
would choose something had spent a lot
of times choosing something that was
that they really were passionate about
learning and then they would spend the
entire course just immersed in that
question and they spin off different
kinds of texts of different genres from
that and he said that by the end of the
course they were writing with so much
more authority and confidence and depth
about these topics because they weren't
facing a new topic every two weeks
that's another thing I think we need to
think about is to what extent we're
really giving students unreasonable
kinds of tasks you know that don't allow
them to to know what we wait about
things we know about and we often don't
give them the chance to really know
something to write about it effectively
so those are what you thought
I can add something to that I think it
seems to me that in addition to giving
students unfamiliar kinds of texts there
are certain very familiar text that they
encounter all the time and never really
read and a lot of these are the texts i
call sacred texts political sacred texts
religious cycle text you know if you if
you just get your sacred texts in a
certain place if you get your religious
sacred texts always being interpreted
for you buy buy buy some minister or a
priest you probably have never really
read that sacred that sacred texts and I
think that using the kinds of skills
that we developed with the literary
texts and turning them on the sacred
texts can be a very exciting thing take
a simple example God appears and says i
am the lord thy god thou shalt have no
other gods before me question does God
think there are no other gods or does
God think there are other gods and he
just wants to be the first in line you
know I think that reading these things
really reading these things and reading
what is not said as well as what is said
you know when you're told that you shall
not covet thy neighbor's wife or his ox
or his ass or his maidservant or his man
sir there is nothing in there about not
coveting husband you know why not
because husbands are the covetous
they're the owners you know and if you
if you if you read those texts and don't
read what isn't being said you will
never understand what sort of creature
this God is of course he's not a
creature either creator right but you
know what I mean what sort of creator
this God
that put it that way I think that
putting these sacred texts putting the
Second Amendment putting the 14th
amendment amusing out there and say
let's really read them let's read them
with all of the intensity and skill that
we develop from looking at other kinds
of other kinds of texts I think that can
be very exciting if we have the courage
to do that you know sacred texts have
have a certain problem and my own theory
of reading is a three-part theory yes
first of all and I like to explain this
to students and say for the texts are
going to look at we're going to do it in
three stages first stage reacting just
immediate response you like it you're
not like it de the agree with it not
agree with it second stage where is it
coming from what though what did it mean
to the person or persons who created it
can we go back to that stage back to as
odd and says them there then go back to
them there then and ask what it what it
meant to them and then the third stage
criticism they okay if it meant that to
them there then what does it mean to us
here now and do we want to accept that
if if we think that that God seems to be
a man speaking to other men and that
women are dealt with that property there
do we do we want do we really want that
religion you know that we need that
that's the critical stage and I think
that there's a lot that we can do to
energize our classrooms by getting the
sacred texts in there and i also think
we need to do profane text and in
another way but but the sacred texts
belong and in our curriculum in in the
curriculum that studies reading and
writing that's a way of saying things
are more complicated than this which i
think i think ought to be a template for
every politician before they run for
office yeah on that by the way I just
Nancy I understand that it certainly can
be irritating when students take a
formula like that complication formula
sort of beat it to death but I have to
say that we're teaching a lot of
students now we wish they would do that
you know we question so it's not the
worst thing when students kind of turn
our stuff into cliches a lot of them
don't know yet how to do that it's
really brings me that I was delighted
that when Jack Burton said and I wrote
down what he says at the amount of
mystification in academia is a calling I
don't think I can be said to you
strongly I mean yeah I don't get the
feeling that we act as if we worried you
know we care about that that much that
it has much urgency to us I think we
should but I think when we do worry
about the mystification in academia and
how how unsuccessful we often aren't
getting getting through to our students
we act as if it's a matter of individual
teaching or of individual core strategy
or even and Bob I've earned the right to
make this mild suggestion because I've
taught you we taught your books for many
years are the best things around for
teaching current advanced literary
culture making it clear to students who
don't understand it which is most but
you know Kate we could change the
subject matter and and and stress
textuality much more than we now do d
privilege literature privilege sexuality
blossom still would be very confused in
fact some might be more so because it's
inherently hard to think that way and I
think that too and this goes back to our
approach you know teach me we have to
get beyond the level of individual
individual courses individual subject
matter to make a dent in this problem we
have to start thinking collectively on
how the students see us has a collective
body faculties or eggheads educated
types the university still acts as if
it's up to them to figure us out and if
they don't it's their fault you know
it's not our fault we assess minh thi
think somebody brought it up is has a
potential to change that situation
because we have to start asking well how
much you a lot of what we're putting out
there is actually being learned and then
we have to think of we this assessment
is not just about what I teach you what
you teach or what I do in my course
really like say about what kind of sense
they make of us and that's that's why
captain I I don't try to focus on the
totality that that's coming across to
them and why the the question of mixed
messages and commonality it seems to me
becomes important any comments from the
audience please come on up
mm-hmm you have to get to a microphone
no right what but the video I want to
make a comment on behalf of your son's
need for a story I think it's very
important for children to internalize
the stories because that's how they
develop their stories and I remember
stories that i read in grade school that
i have never forgotten about personal
bravery or compassion and i think that's
the way children build so i say hats off
to your boys any other common it's not
I'm going to declare the session
adjourned and people can try to avoid
responsible
[Music]
[Applause]